I'm never one who really shied away from
a challenge I usually kind of jump at
the opportunity to do something
different and unexpected I've been the
negative Road and I've been the positive
road and I would never give up the
positive Road it just gives me between
my physical fitness and my faith I have
so much discipline in my life when I
said I wanted to be an actor people kind
of shot gold and then when I said I
wanted to be a serious actor people
chuckle no when I he's an American actor
producer businessman rapper and former
model he's the co-owner of the wall
burgers restaurant chain and co-stars in
the reality TV show about it he received
a star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame on
July 29 2010 he's Mark Wahlberg and here
is my take on his top 10 rules for
success rule number one is my personal
favorite and make sure to stick around
all the way to the end for some special
bonus clips also as Marcus talking if he
says something that really inspires you
make sure to copy it down into the
comments below and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well
I mean as terrible as it is the kid who
had the girls in the neighborhood who
had the nicest car and sold the most
drugs you know there wasn't really
anybody that I could look up to that was
from my situation I really made
something of himself
that's why I feel is so important to
stay true to who I am and where I'm from
you know because kids like myself do
look up to me you know and I came
through it the right way you know so it
really you know makes them gives them
something to look at you know and
something to work for you know and
that's why I've accomplished really
everything that I've set out to do but
to to just stop and not stay on that
mission I think would be wrong too
because things are still getting worse
you know what I'm saying playing a
professor in college it was a bit of a
stretch but something that I was excited
about I'm never one who really shied
away from a challenge I usually kind of
jump at the opportunity to do something
different and unexpected but I'm also
the kind of guy who's going to make sure
that I'm prepared you know really cover
all the bases and and you know I don't
want to to look foolish and I don't
certainly don't want a disappoint back
growing up tough time yeah
somewhere I mean could that kid look at
you today and could you ever imagine
that it would turn out this way
you know somebody asked me last night
they said what if market mark met Mark
Wahlberg right now yeah and I said well
if I didn't get to say the first word he
probably punched me in the face but you
know if I got to talk to him I think I
think he would understand and and maybe
change his ways just ah I do what Marky
Mark was zoom then ah Marky Mark was was
the trumped up version of who I was in
the street when I was younger and wild
and you know like everybody else just
driving drugs I'm selling drugs and
trying to be the toughest guy in the
neighborhood you know trying to impress
the girls by you know stealing a car so
I'm just just just really foolish though
but that was really all that that I was
I was accustomed to that's all that I
could see you know I started on the
street yeah yeah how'd you pull out of
that ah well I got incarcerated I like
like most people and I think I was the
only one who didn't like it and and I
couldn't figure that out everybody was
just so content with them there would be
the winter because it was cold outside
and they don't get the free meals and
everything else
I just knew everybody that just looked
like one of the corners of my
neighborhood and I said well if I want
anything else out of this life I've got
to start now and do what you do I just
prayed you know started focusing on my
family and looking at all the stuff that
I put my mom through being the youngest
of nine she wasn't she wasn't really
around enough she was always working two
jobs my dad worked two jobs so I was
kind of you know just free to run the
streets went on the streets but she
never knew and of course she would never
think that her baby her little boy would
do anything wrong so so uh I just I just
looked at at all those things and and I
realized that I couldn't blame it on my
neighborhood anymore
I know right from wrong in the back of
my mind and I need to do what's right
and if not just get used to the
environment that I'm in you know you
have two choices in life basically it's
it's basically to succeed or to fail you
know I'm saying and I've been the
negative Road and I've been the positive
road and I would never give up the
positive Road never I would never even
if you know I'm saying if I was the
biggest flop in the world how different
do you think your career and possibly
your life would have been had you not
embraced the physical fitness part early
on oh man you know it just gives me
between my physical fitness and my faith
I have so much discipline in my life
and I have such a positive outlook on
life and you know the opportunities that
I have and the things that I've been
able to accomplish in my life that it
starts out you know I'm up in the 4:30
in the morning I'm in the kitchen having
breakfast five o'clock I'm in the gym
6:30 I've already had another shake and
7:30 I'm eating a couple of turkey
burgers dropping the kids off at school
and by nine o'clock I'm having another
meal and I've already been to church and
worked out and you know I feel like
there isn't anything that I can't
accomplish was the departed one for them
or one for you the party was one for me
and one for Marty you know when you get
a chance to work with Marty Scorsese you
got to show up and you get enough uh
they didn't pay me at all but you know
did you do it for scale I did it was
pretty cheap I don't know if it was
scale but it was pretty cheap you know
but hey I guess you ten million for
Planet of the Apes you can go I can do
one more exactly exactly well you got to
do ten for free to make up for that one
but uh
but uh no you know you got an
opportunity work with Marty Scorsese I
don't mind cutting a check to have that
opportunity the way to prove yourself is
to better yourself now in a coup for up
this he's hitting up their small
business campaign I said I wanted to be
an actor they last him and I said I want
to be a producer they told me to stay in
my lane and I said I want to open up a
restaurant instead it would never happen
but it did happen my Wahlberg thanks for
joining us in the ad you say that when
you told people back in Massachusetts
that you want to be an actor that you
would laugh that why did they laugh at
you well first I was beaten up and then
I was laughed at right you know it's one
of those things it was just never really
cool to want to be in the arts you know
you were either gonna be a police
officer or crook or if you were lucky
enough to to get out as an athlete or if
you were smart enough to get to go to
one of the great educational institutes
in and around the Boston area
my brother has a lot of success and
stuff and I'm having album coming up and
um I worked hard for it though you know
saying a lot of people will think all
his brothers rich and this and that you
know he's just you know I'm saying
everything you can hand it to him you
know a lot of people say that to me now
I worked hard for it though you know and
is there a type of genre film maybe you
haven't done that you bought to explore
and if there is I'm gonna do it I'll
take a crack at it you know I always
wanted to be able to do it all you know
I waited for the right time to kind of
creep into the comedy thing and you know
it's been it's been good so far and you
know I just I want to be able to do it
all yeah who's stopping you do you think
nobody but you know when we look when I
said I wanted to be an actor people kind
of shackled and then when I said I
wanted to be a serious actor people
chuckle know when I you know I could
play the tough guy role when I wanted to
do the vulnerable thing book you nice
people like now that's just he's this
other guy and so you know when I wanted
to Kali
well you've been funny in movies but
it's comedy is a different thing I
didn't want to look like an actor who
could box I wanted to look like a boxer
who could win the World title train
right here at his home in Beverly Hills
this is where we choreographed all the
fights Wahlberg built a boxing Mecca
complete with a top-of-the-line ring you
took this seriously we were in here
eight 10 hours a day but it was here
that he brought the real brothers Micky
and Dicky to help with his training mark
trained for the role for four years not
knowing whether one frame of the film
would ever be shocked the fighter almost
didn't get made directors and kostas
came and went
did you ever think you know gosh I'm
never gonna get this made this is just
impossible there was certainly times
where I would wake up at 4:30 in the
morning you know my trainer would ring
the bell and of a cop gosh I was like I
better get this movie made and I kill
somebody if I don't get it hey did you
get obsessed with it I was yeah
I was what made you say this is the one
what was it about it I was such a huge
Micky Ward fan always even bro yeah yeah
yeah I mean God you know the name Micky
Ward was to me like the name Larry Bird
just a local sports hero
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because J star Killa
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I just love to
know which of Marc's 10 rules have the
biggest impact on you and why what
change you're going to make in your life
for business after watching this video
what had the you know richest thought
process Edition to you leave it in the
comments below and I will join in the
discussion finally I want to give a
quick shout out to safe more tazza thank
you so much for buying the copy of my
book it really means a lot to me those
you're watching if you want a chance at
a shout out in the future video make
sure to pick up a copy of the book and
email in your receipt so we can keep
track and give you the bonuses - thank
you guys so much for watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you soon
what one quality you think you've have
that made you and gave you and allowed
you push you to achieve what you have um
I think my uh my willingness to learn
I'm pretty relentless when it comes to
that you know I certainly knew
everything about growing up in the
street and you know what it took to
survive on the street corner Dorchester
but uh this is a whole new world to me
so you know just uh being able to take
advantage of the things that I've that
I've seen and you know the things that
I've been exposed to now with my career
it's really pin now you've been a show
business a long time haven't you too
long no not down on your right catch
though how old were you when you first
when you were Marky Mark eighteen
eighteen years old yeah and then and
then
and who would I get all of the groups
confused it was a new kids in the hall
new kids on the block new key new kids
on the block out that was your brother
yeah and but we and you whose group were
you in I was in Marky Mark and the Funky
Bunch
oh the funky alley I had been a funky
bun
I had been kind of involved with the new
kids before they actually formulated the
group my brother and I were working with
a producer Maurice Starr and then I was
like we started out making a rap album
and then it turned into like us going to
vocal lessons and dance dance class I
was like this is not what I want to do
you know then I end up going to jail and
watching them on TV they're making
millions and millions oh really no they
performed at the jail wait a minute no
stop right there sure how old were you
when you went to jail
seventeen seventeen and may I ask why
for doing bad things bad things and I
don't recommend you ever go there
especially with the capsid problem
again another helpful piece of advice
did it have to do something with
controlled substances that always weighs
into the equation was it was it the
thieving thievery
all of those things all in about how
long were you gone long enough to never
want to go back all together I did like
two and a half months but as an you know
being tried as an adult
get your attention yeah and I was
probably five 110 pounds oh so so your
brother and his buddies were performing
on TV you're in prison
yeah and they came to the jail to
perform and then when I would be
watching in the record room I'd be like
that's my brother they're like yes shut
up and that's like no I was in that
group but they're like we are the
dumbest forever she's like because now
you're in he was lucky enough that Wow
my brother came back and you know when I
got and and then I was able to you know
start my own career words of wisdom well
by God but that's it for heaven sakes
and now look at you you're a big-time
movie star you got a lovely family
you've learned the lessons the hard way
in life and and your bet now do your
kids know about your time away no they
don't
yeah will that be a different will be a
difficult conversation will it no more
difficult than daddy didn't finish high
school although I am going back now they
have this new program in Massachusetts
where you can actually take the courses
online so I'm starting this month in New
Orleans I'm gonna go get my high school
diploma
and also I'm the ambassador to Taco
Bell's graduate to go program they asked
me to do this and it's like dude I never
graduated why would you pick me to do
this yeah now is it what you're doing is
it different than the GED yes it's an
actual diploma see I've got to take up
all the courses that I missed and I'm a
little nervous but you know what I've
got a lot of time money how much do you
have to make up I quit I never graduated
the ninth grade so I quit kind of during
the ninth grade so she said my geometry
scores are pretty good they're gonna
give me whatever credits already had
which is probably like one or two but
I'm gonna make it happen it's one of
those things where I go and I gotta make
it how now will it take another three
years do you think I can do it you know
I have a lot of downtime on sets in the
trailer enough so I can just I just want
to blast through it hopefully I'll be
able to do it maybe six or eight money
go out for the track team
I would love to could he loves it
I want the whole deal I want the captain
down
it's important to matter how we'll try
and I'd love to you know I'd love to at
some point go to film school well this
is this is a great example this is a
great example for not just your family
but I mean my god because how many
people are in a situation that seems
insurmountable see I mean at 17 who
would have bet on you honest to god who
wouldn't yeah and now look at you I'm
very fortunate yeah
and and what and why what what is
different about you what what what
changed in your life was it the stretch
in prison something else a lot of things
you know I'm a very you know very much
into my faith and you know I just wanted
to turn my life around no matter what I
was doing whether I was working on a
construction site driving a tow truck
which was my last real job whatever I
was doing I was going to end up on the
right side of the law and I was going to
be a positive productive persons and